[Music]  the rugby park footballers memorial was  established on the 7th of september  1924. these gates were a memorial to the  more than 200 southland rugby players  killed during the first world war  proportionally due to southland's  population it is the largest loss of  rugby players  per region in new zealand at the time  the gates consist of eight concrete  pillars and dispersed with ward iron  the two main pillars are surmounted with  wrought iron crosses the other two are  inscribed with memorial tablets  the rightmost pillar was altered after  the second world war to include the  dates  1939-1945 the gates are inscribed to the  honored memory of those southern players  who fell in the great war  egypt gallipoli france belgium and  palestine